[Music]
new at 11 a henderson's mom desperate
plea to bring her 11 year old daughter
back home the girl went missing saturday
evening and there has not been any trace
of her victoria saha joins us live in
henderson now with this story
this is 11 year old ashlyn scheer her
mom says she was riding her skateboard
outside her house on pacific cascades
when she vanished
i just want my baby
mom alison thomas has had what feels
like the longest couple of days of her
life without a word from her daughter
ashlynn a typical saturday turned into
devastation the entire day was
completely normal
she
we hung out together on saturday evening
ashlynne went to the park and even let
her mom know when she was making her way
back home after returning home she
decides to ride her skateboard outside
it was the last time thomas saw her
daughter wasn't five minutes later
i opened the front door and i don't see
her her skateboard left in the middle of
the road iphone messages went green and
calls went unanswered your call has been
forwarded to an automated voice
messaging system she's never
not texted me thomas is fearing the
worst she says ashlyn suffers from
anxiety and depression she kept her
herself a lot but when ashley went
missing she saw an app on her daughter's
computer called discord enabling a chat
room with strangers the person was
saying things that
you know
you're my princess you know you know
like things like that that a little girl
that is starving for attention from her
peers wants to hear thomas says some of
those comments made toward her
11-year-old daughter were also sexual
thomas turned over everything she could
to henderson police i truly believe that
she met somebody that made her feel all
those things she wished she could feel
and is hoping and praying someone can
recognize ashlynn and bring her home was
taken thursday two days before she went
missing ashland was last seen wearing
heavy makeup and colored streaks on her
hair but this is how she looks without
it
ashlyn has not had any of her medication
since the day she went missing her
family has set up a gofundme with a
reward for anyone that can help bring
ashland home back safely reporting live
from henderson tonight victoria zaha
live local now